c'était il ya moins de trois semaines
fin mars le président du conseil
présidentiel libyen mohamed el menfi
rencontré le président turc à ankara
avant la rencontre de ce lundi cette
visite du nouvel exécutif libyen
illustrent et déjà la proximité très
forte entre deux pays liés par des
accords militaires et économiques mais
tripoli souhaite prendre de la distance
la libye a ainsi officiellement demandé
à la turquie de retirer ses troupes
présentes sur son sol d'ici la fin du
mois de mai une intervention qui dure
depuis plus d'un an maintenant
elle avait été annoncée devant le
parlement turc par recep tayyip erdogan
en décembre 2019 mais nous allons
présenter la mention pour l'envoi de
soldats en libye dès la reprise des
travaux du parlement
si dieu le veut nous pourrons le faire
adopter le 8 ou le 9 janvier et répondre
ainsi favorablement à l'invitation du
gouvernement libyen légitime
nous avons soutenu et continueront à
soutenir par tous les moyens le
gouvernement de tripoli qui résistent
contre un général putschiste soutenue
par des pays arabes et européens pour
ankara il s'agissait alors de contrer
l'offensive menée par les forces du
principal rival du gouvernement de
l'époque le maréchal rallye faf tard
homme fort de l'est du pays depuis un
cessez le feu entre les deux camps est
entrée en vigueur et la turquie semble
prêt à rediscuter sa présence militaire
mais ankara souhaite préserver ses
intérêts économiques en libye notamment
en multipliant les investissements et en
participant activement à la
reconstruction du pays
alors que le nouveau gouvernement libyen
doit gérer les affaires courantes
jusqu'aux élections prévues fin décembre
l'union européenne et les etats unis
exigent un retrait rapide de toutes les
troupes étrangères de libye et notamment
les troupes turques en rappel à l'ordre
repris par le président français moi je
pense que l'une des situations les plus
graves c'est ce qui se passe en libye
vous l'avez dit malgré la conférence
qu'on avait tenu à berlin car qui n'a
pas tenu sa parole elle envoyer des
combattants étrangers elle a envoyé son
armée
moi je mets beaucoup de pression pour
qu'on ait maintenant un retrait la
présence turque en libye a également été
évoqué il ya quelques jours lors de la
visite à ankara de haut représentant
européen bruxelles qui souhaite ne pas
fermer la porte à des discussions avec
la turquie
en guise d'encouragement lieux s'est dit
prête à reprendre le dialogue au niveau
suspendu en 2019 sur certains sujets
notamment la sécurité l'environnement et
certaines facilités de visas pour les
ressortissants turcs